Even when a movie is original, it isn’t
an entirely new idea per say.
By now, just about every story has been told
and the works of yesteryear inspire the ones
of today.
It isn’t out of the question for some movies
to bear similarities to others, but there
are times when Hollywood really scratches
the bottom of the barrel.
There are numerous instances of studios releasing
“twin” films, which are projects with
nearly identical setups that come out just
months apart from each other.
It happens more often than you’d think.
Here are 10 twin movies suspiciously released
at the same time.
Jobs and Steve Jobs
With both based on the life of tech icon Steve
Jobs, there were obvious parallels between
Jobs and Steve Jobs.
The proximity of their release dates was the
stranger fact.
Following Jobs’ death in 2011, there was
a race to get a biopic off the ground.
The Ashton Kutcher starring Jobs was the first
in theaters, but was a critical dud.
Two years later, Michael Fassbender teamed
up with Danny Boyle and Aaron Sorkin for a
different take – one that was far better
received, yet bombed at the box office.
Fassbender was nominated for an Oscar, but
neither left much of an impact when it was
all said and done.
No Strings Attached and Friends With Benefits
Even the most devout cinephile can’t keep
these two straight.
Released in 2011, No Strings Attached and
Friends With Benefits both featured a couple
of attractive people agreeing to engage in
a casual sex-based relationship, only to fall
in love later on.
They were even both called Friends With Benefits
when they started production.
To avoid a further mix-up, Paramount changed
the name of their project, and both ended
up becoming hits at the box office.
They may not have reinvented the rom-com wheel,
but there are worse ways to spend a date night.
This is the End and The World’s End
Friends Simon Pegg and Seth Rogen discovered
through conversation that they were coincidentally
working on similar apocalyptic films about
a group of friends trying to survive a catastrophic
event.
The main difference between the two was that
in Rogen’s This is the End, the actors are
playing fictionalized versions of themselves,
whereas The World’s End is a more traditional
narrative film with the cast portraying original
characters.
Fortunately for moviegoers, they both served
up plenty of laughs and thrills, earning excellent
reviews and posting high figures at the box
office.
We guess audiences just love watching the
world explode.
It’s a premise that never gets old.
Mission to Mars and Red Planet
Any sci-fi fan has dreamed about traveling
to Mars, and it’s long been a staple of
Hollywood films – well before The Martian
was nominated for Oscars.
In 2000, Disney released Mission to Mars,
a film that was based on a Tomorrowland ride
that had closed in the 1990s.
It proved to be somewhat successful, which
is more than we can say for Red Planet, which
was also about a trip to Mars.
That movie bombed so poorly, director Antony
Hoffman never worked on a big time feature
again.
Neither performed all that well with critics
though, so it’s hard to call Disney the
out and out winner here.
Megamind and Despeciable Me
Even by 2010, we had already had several superhero
movies.
What about on focusing on a villain?
Hollywood determined the time was right for
two such projects as this decade began – releasing
Megamind and Despicable Me.
Both were about evildoers with a heart of
gold who redeem themselves by stopping a larger,
greater threat.
Since Megamind came out after Despicable Me,
it was criticized for copying off of the formula
– even though the two were probably in production
at the same time.
What gave Despicable Me the edge were the
Minions, who are now just as popular on their
own as the film series.
There’s still no Megamind 2.
Observe and Report and Paul Blart: Mall Cop
Who knew mall security could be so funny?
Comedies Observe and Report and Paul Blart:
Mall Cop looked to give these underappreciated
law enforcers the spotlight in 2009, with
Seth Rogen and Kevin James out to prove that
mall policemen were more than just a punchline.
There seemed to be room for both, since they
were going after very different audiences.
Observe and Report was a classic, R-rated
Rogen vehicle, while Paul Blart aimed more
for family laughs with a PG rating.
While neither was a critical darling, Paul
Blart was the overwhelming victor at the box
office, making enough to earn a sequel.
Chasing Liberty and First Daughter
Political movies can always be interesting
– especially in an election year.
As US citizens geared up for the 2004 presidential
race, Hollywood was asking moviegoers to decide
which film about the president’s daughter
was better: Chasing Liberty or First Daughter.
Both were bland rom-coms with the president’s
daughter as the protagonist, trying to shed
the life of luxury living in the White House
for a more “normal” existence.
Neither film worked all that well, despite
some intriguing talent attached, leading to
both bombing at the box office.
Maybe tales of the First Family aren’t as
fascinating as the one who’s actually in
charge?
Gordy and Babe
There was a boom in talking pig films in the
mid-1990s.
Gordy and Babe were both released just months
apart from each other.
The former was about a pig trying to find
his family after they were taken away to be
slaughtered.
Though it reached theaters first, it was no
match for Babe, which was one of the five
Best Picture nominees of that year.
It even won the Oscar for Best Visual Effects,
breaking new ground in talking animal pictures.
Making it even more incredible is that it’s
from the mind of Mad Max creator George Miller,
so he showed impressive range with this film.
The Equalizer and John Wick
2014 saw two throwback action vehicles find
success critically and at the box office.
Starring Denzel Washington and Keanu Reeves,
the Equalizer and John Wick revolve around
ex-hitmen who come out of retirement to settle
a personal vendetta against the Russian mob.
The motivations were different, but the comparisons
were obvious.
In a weird coincidence, the sequels to both
are scheduled for release in 2017, so these
two blossoming franchises are going to duel
again next year.
If it’s anything like the first round, fans
won’t be complaining and thoroughly enjoy
the ride.
It’s hard to go wrong with either of these
actors in a leading role.
Batman V Superman and Captain America: Civil
War
After years of superhero films being fun escapism
for fans, 2016 decided to double down on the
guilt and emotional toll metahumans face on
a daily basis.
Launching the new DCEU, Batman V Superman
pitted the two iconic heroes together in a
philosophical battle to determine which brand
of justice was more appropriate.
Months later, Marvel released Captain America:
Civil War, which saw the Avengers split into
two factions and debate over the subject of
superhero accountability.
Both had very different critical and box office
performances, but they tackled similar, thought-provoking
concepts to deconstruct their genres.
It was interesting, but we’re looking forward
to the fun again.
Those are our picks for twin movies released
at the same time.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones do you prefer?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!